ladies and gentlemen welcome back from
lunch it's my pleasure to now introduce
to you our speaker this afternoon Molly
Hemingway let me just say a few words
about Ms Hemingway she is a senior
journalism fellow here at Hillsdale
College a senior editor at the
Federalist and a Fox News contributor
she's been a Philips foundation
journalism fellow a lincoln fellow at
the Claremont Institute for the Study of
statesmanship and political philosophy
and a Eugene C Pullman distinguished
Visiting Fellow in journalism here at
the college she's also written numerous
publications for including the Wall
Street Journal the Claremont Review of
Books USA Today ricochet the Los Angeles
time the Washington Post the federal
Times and Christianity today she is the
author of Trump versus the media and
co-author of justice on trial the
Cavanaugh confirmation and the future of
the Supreme Court would you please
welcome Molly Hemingway
thank you
okay you you all are completely
ridiculous but thank you very much it is
such an honor to be here and I can't
believe what we just got to experience
this morning I was so moved by the music
the readings the speeches and I'm so
glad that I got to be part of it I was
kind of wondering if the students
realized what they were participating in
or if it will take a few more years
before they realize the significance and
how special today was but we're here
celebrating the 175th anniversary of
Hillsdale College but it is a year with
many important anniversaries for
instance it is the 25th anniversary of
Al Gore saying one of my favorite things
he ever said and I would you realize
that students here on campus are too
young to have actually experienced Al
Gore they weren't alive in the 1990s so
they might not remember that he was
known when he was vice president for
saying really ridiculous things and
saying some pretty ridiculous things in
the years after being vice president as
well he predicted the Earth's ice caps
would melt by 2014 so that's another
really important anniversary we've had
five years with no ice caps as Al Gore
predicted but most of his farcical
observations are best forgotten but one
has proved prescient and revealing if
unintentionally so in the process of
praising America's legacy of ethnic
tolerance or aspiring thinking that we
could do better in the future he said
America can be e pluribus unum which he
translated as out of one many
it was what in DC was called a classic
Kinsley gaff coined by deceased
commentator Michael Kinsley that's when
a politician reveals some truth that
they did not intend to admit and over a
quarter century ago he was inadvertently
saying something that has subsequently
become something of an article of faith
among many on the left having a shared
identity as Americans a shared set of
constitutional principles and having
those laid out in our founding documents
and all sharing them is increasingly
something that people don't desire or
see so let's put a pin in that and move
on to another anniversary which is the
tenth anniversary of the launch of the
Tea Party On February 19 2009 CNBC
editor Rick Santelli was on the floor of
the Chicago Stock Exchange and wondered
whether there should be something of a
tea party in response to these various
corporate bailouts that were happening
at that time the remarks were actually
pretty brief but they struck a huge
chord with average Americans who were
fed up with what was happening in the
federal government this was right after
the end of the Bush presidency that had
ended with massive bank bailouts and the
700 billion dollar troubled asset relief
program requiring requiring middle-class
average Americans to pay for other
people's mismanagement problems the
movement grew grassroots activists
gathered locally at the state level
repeatedly at the national level to
protest the burgeoning administrative
state and its awarding of additional
power and money to unelected
corporations and unelected bureaucrats
then came the Affordable Care Act rammed
through Congress against the fervent
pleas of many Americans the group was
completely organic for better and for
worse it had no TV savvy leaders it had
no public relations staff their members
were very much in the middle class a lot
of people had backgrounds
the military and in business they were a
natural gift to the Republican Party
because they were just tons of people
arguing for what the Republican Party
claimed to support lowered taxes a
decrease in the size and scope of the
administrative state a an easing up or
lightening of the regulatory burden
we're arguing for fiscal sobriety and
personal responsibility and they were
really good at political organization
the movement was responsible in 2010 for
the largest shift in seats in the House
of Representatives since 1948
Republicans picked up seven Senate seats
flipped control of 20 state legislatures
and picked up another six gubernatorial
seats it's really important at a time
when redistricting was happening and
other issues at the state level but the
response to the group was fascinating
the media couldn't or chose not to
understand the group or view them as a
threat and immediately characterized
what they were doing as racist which is
their go-to slur the Democrats
understood the party of the tea party
and fought them valiantly but the
response from many Republicans was
surprisingly hostile as well Mitch
McConnell who's a main player in my book
that I wrote with Kerry suberino said in
2014 I think we're going to crush them
everywhere he said referring to the Tea
Party I don't think they're gonna have a
single nominee anywhere in the country
and he was right they didn't that year
he won his primary in Kentucky thad
Cochran won his primary in Mississippi
and Pat Roberts won his seat in Kansas
other tea party or tea party type
figures in that and other years have
fared better including senators Rand
Paul Marco Rubio Ted Cruz Ben Sasse but
McConnell's point stands he said they
would be crushed an in large part by
joining with Democrats and the media and
others the establishment did
successfully crush them they kept the
insurgents at bay co-opted a lot of the
people that came remember what happened
with that Affordable Care Act people who
didn't like it we're told you just need
to elect us to the House of
Representatives and we'll take care of
it and they did 2010 we just talked
about it that largest turnover in seats
so oh the house isn't enough you need to
give us the Senate as well and these
people got out there and they managed to
take the Senate as well and nothing
happened so okay okay you got to give us
the presidency too and then we'll really
take care of it and so they did that
they against insurmountable odds
seemingly insurmountable odds they take
the presidency in 2016 and I understand
that it's complicated
I understand the Senate majority was
very narrow but it turned out that they
did not succeed in overturning Obamacare
and so with that there's the sobering
realization that the small government
movement that was the tea party kind of
died at that moment it's also perhaps
worth just remembering that there was an
element of this in the Reagan
administration as well many people began
to see the futility of taking on the
bureaucracy and truly beating it back
President Reagan tried to do this with
various things and they by and large
didn't work even take reining in the EPA
he appointed the mother of current
Supreme Court justice Neil Gorsuch to
deregulate to move regulatory control to
the states instead of at the federal
level and she was pretty much run out of
town within two years other efforts seem
to be met with similar ends but with the
crushing of the Tea Party many Americans
who earnestly thought that they could
stand up against the state found out
that they were wrong it left many
Americans realizing that the
administrative state the bureaucracy the
unelected bureaucracy could not be
dismantled and that all future political
battles might have to be for mere
survival against encroaching forces
those who argue for a limited government
who know that the state can only grow at
the expense of the liberty of the people
learned a really tragic lesson the
notion that the people could demand that
the government of Washington DC be
reduced the
something of a sad joke so did much of
the conservative or the traditional
conservative and libertarian arguments
that failed to take into account the new
power dynamics in play and one of those
new dynamics was the sudden lurch left
and increasing power of corporations not
content with the mere crony capitalism
that they'd had before they now are
fully entrenched within the
administrative state relying on them for
their growth and encouraging progressive
social change to ensure compliance from
the people but more embroiled and
powerful these large corporations become
in people's lives the more they control
the contours of public debate
understanding this treatment of these
and other voters these Tea Party and
other voters and how they have been
crushed by elected representatives
frittering away their article one powers
to the unelected bureaucracy that serves
as judge jury and executioner in
political life is key to making sense of
this current moment that we're in it
explains why so many of the candidates
that were offered to voters in the last
cycle failed you remember Senator John
McCain gave a grace gracious concession
speech to Barack Obama I think that was
where he said although it might have
been later that he viewed it as an honor
to lose to him and Mitt Romney's
concession speech was likewise quite
dignified and both men were known for
working very well with opponents of
conservatism but a lot of voters didn't
want that they didn't want dignified
beautiful concession speeches or
cooperation with progressive leaders and
they don't even want to hear people give
lectures about conservatism that fail to
address this new reality they already
realized there was no taking on of the
state and they wanted someone who would
help them protect their way of life from
encroachment progressives promised to
fundamentally transform live that's a
quote from former President Obama
America and they set about to do it and
leaders a lot of leaders in conservatism
don't take that seriously enough it was
kind of silly how many people expected
conservative voters to just continued
to accept this business as usual at this
point I would like to do something very
unwise which is slightly pushback
against something mark Stein said so you
know how this is gonna go very poorly
but the last question that was asked
last night was about the media and I
completely share mark's viewpoint that
freedom of the press is extremely
important
there is a reason freedom of the press
is bundled with speech and religious
rights and freedom of association we
know that we must be free to seek the
truth and the press is a very important
part of that for preserving our Liberty
Thomas Jefferson who has an eye on
things said that if he had to choose
between government and newspapers he
would pick newspapers because people
need to be informed and I share a love
for the press and it's my life's work
and I really wish that we lived up to
what our responsibilities are to keep
people informed but I don't think
they're without blame for some of what
has happened in recent years it is my
view that the press the media are the
primary political actors in our midst
they're openly hostile to preserving
limited constitutional government and
that hostility is a threat conservatives
have complained about media bias for
decades
I think Eisenhower was the first
Republican president to do so in his
speeches by the time of George HW Bush
his most popular campaign slogan was
also on a bumper sticker that I remember
in his re-election campaign which was
annoy the media reelect Bush
the media responds to complaints of bias
has been to ignore them or accuse
critics of trying to influence the news
improperly but the big response the main
response that they have it has been
simply to get worse by the 2016 campaign
you had journalists willfully and openly
admitting that they were not playing
things straight that they defended this
posture because in their view Donald
Trump was an existential threat and when
he won the 2016 election against every
single media predict prediction out
there a few people except accepted a no
point in the media responded by
basically throwing temper tantrums and
endorsing every crazed conspiracy theory
in their midst the biggest one they
bought into happened to be one shared by
Hillary Clinton hours after her election
she gathered with advisers and they
decided to lean back into a campaign
message that they had worked very hard
to spread but they felt had not gotten
enough play it was that Trump was
illegitimate because Russian meddling in
the election and his treasonous
collusion with same despite this theory
being absurd on its face the media
believed it or pretended to believe it
fervently this crazed conspiracy theory
dominated media coverage of the incoming
Trump administration in the first few
years of that administration a dossier
with hearsay allegations was published
and despite what most average Americans
could see it was silly it was ridiculous
it was difficult to believe the media
treated it as if it were credible and
really worth analyzing and digging into
the Attorney General was sidelined from
oversight of the Department of Justice
because of media reports that he was a
Russian spy to this day the notion of
Jeff Sessions from Alabama being a
Russian spy is my favorite part of the
entire Russia conspiracy theory it
caused a lot of damage a special counsel
was launched and while it ran through a
great deal of money and rang up many
people on processed crimes the end was a
complete
dud there was no collusion with Russia
to steal the 2016 election not by Trump
not by anyone his companion his campaign
not by a single American which is
actually kind of amazing you would
assume that in a country with hundreds
of millions of people you got some rogue
people out there doing something instead
they put forth a novel theory that Trump
by complaining about falsely being
accused of being a traitor had
obstructed justice that theory failed to
take root - with a heavy assist from
Robert Moeller who testified on Capitol
Hill so the world could see that he
really did not have control over the
probe whose credibility rested on his
name I remember that day that he
testified my mother told me that she had
not read the Moller report but she was
pretty sure she had a better handle on
it than Robert Muller did we also might
take a minute to note media coverage of
another story I'm very familiar with
which is the Cavanaugh confirmation
battle the president nominated a
respected federal judge for the court
and the media immediately said about
fighting him fighting against the
nomination they end up publicizing
boride allegations without any
supporting evidence whatsoever this
really is a break from how you know I
know we complain about the media or
people in America complain about the
media a lot but even a few decades ago
you would have not seen quite this Glee
with publicizing these lurid allegations
without any supporting evidence
most recently the New York Times tried
to hit him again with another smear by
failing to tell readers that they well
they said they had an allegation against
him which was and physically improbable
in somewhat ridiculous allegation they
neglected to tell readers that the
alleged victim had never said that she
was a victim and that she had said
through mole and she had not spoken to
these reporters but she had said through
multiple friends she has no such
recollection of any incident they kept
that from readers the trail of failure
associated with the media in recent
years is breck is breathtaking there was
the smear of the pro-life teens from
coming
in Kentucky who were falsely accused of
racial intimidation you had grown
journalists grilling 16 year old boys
about their behavior when it was the
journalists who got everything wrong
there are so many stories that are
debunked it's basically impossible to
tally them all the media are not tiring
they have big plans they obviously now
have a huge impeachment plan and it can
be viewed that they are running the
impeachment effort more than the
Democratic politicians themselves the
New York Times recently announced that
the implosion of the Russian narrative
had left their newsroom reeling and that
they were trying to rebuild their
newsroom around racial narratives
interesting first off to note that they
built their entire newsroom around
pushing this conspiracy theory that
anyone with even moderate intelligence
could have had could have seen reason to
be skeptical about and when it imploded
the editor said that really hit us hard
and now we're trying to rebuild by
claiming that our political opponents
are all racist they said this in a
transcript that was leaked that
everybody can read but as part of that
campaign they launched the 16:19 project
to mark the 400th anniversary of slavery
in the United States the project makes
Al Gore's misstatement of the American
motto look quaint it's not just out of
one many but a reformulation of what the
country is founded upon to explicitly
reject our founding documents and their
meaning now it is perfectly fine and
even good for the New York Times and all
of America to mark the 400th anniversary
of slavery in this country is a somber
an important historical marker and
reminder of what humans are capable of
doing against each other that's not what
The Times is doing and what so far is to
say that this 400th anniversary is the
true founding of the country not 1776
when our forefathers risked their lives
to say all men were created equal the
lead essay says that all of that
rhetoric was meaningless because the
real reason for the Revolutionary War
was to preserve slavery in America
nevermind that slavery had been in
America for 150 years under the rule of
an English king or that slavery did not
start out as an American institution
there's a huge difference between saying
the country was founded on the belief
that all men were created equal and that
it took us far too long to realize that
ideal and saying it was disingenuous
from the start not to mention how many
Americans gave their lives in the Civil
War to make that promise in the
Declaration a reality we were led into
that war or we had to respond to that
war that we were forced into by a man
who explicitly made that argument to the
American people in speeches and official
statements that this was what we owed
because of our founding from the
earliest times there were many Americans
between the founding in the Civil War
that were dedicated to fulfilling the
promise of our Creed's chief among them
for our purposes were the founders of
Hillsdale abolitionists was the first
American College to prohibit in its
charter any discrimination based on race
religion or sex and became an early
force for the abolition of slavery a
higher percentage of Hillsdale students
enlisted in the Civil War than any other
Western College of the more than 400 who
fought to preserve the Union for one the
Congressional Medal of Honor three
became generals and many more served as
regimental commanders 60 gave their
lives that commitment leads to today and
it is in stark contrast to what we see
from a lot of other people I have a
little discouraging here if you don't
mind where I've been thinking it's been
such a wonderful experience to hear some
great minds speak to us these last
couple of days and it reminds me of just
how different Hillsdale is from so many
other institutions that are in the
conservative movement there I'll put it
this way
I'm reminded of how fladam urban
controls his opposition he has a tight
grip on power in Russia and one of the
ways that he does that is by allowing
what he is called the systematic
opposition and the systematic opposition
are people who claim to oppose him but
are given some seats of power and he
genuinely listens to them to make sure
that he doesn't go so far as to lose
control of his power technically they
are in the opposing party from his but
they're generally fine with a
continuation of his government so long
as they get to keep their power and
their money they serve a useful purpose
for Putin I think for too long too many
people in the conservative movement in
DC including too many people in its
media outlets academic institutions
think tanks and otherwise have
functioned as the systemic opposition to
progressive isms March through American
institutions public and private
technically they were opposed and they'd
make sounds about opposing the growth of
the administrative state and the broad
of the culture but they were never
terribly successful at returning the
country to its first principles or
constitutional order despite the
millions of supporters who put them in
power and expected just that expected
not just rhetoric but results I'm
supposed to be talking about the
political divide in America but it seems
to me that this isn't really a political
divide all these things that we're
talking about but a cultural divide one
side believes we are created with
purpose we seek truth in order to do
good we understand human nature and how
it is shared by all of us our laws come
from these beliefs and the founders
wrote them into our documents that form
the basis of our republic another side
embraces a fervent religiosity a secular
religiosity built around the exercise of
raw majoritarian power many cases they
reject reality even if it means the
reality of biological distinctions
between male and female they reject the
very notion of a divine creator who sets
forth rights and wrongs through space
and time
and relatedly there is a rejection of
redemption and forgiveness leading to
brutal ritual punishments and mobs
tearing down neighbors perhaps goes
without saying that along with the new
york times they reject our current form
of government as well it's not a
political divide it is so much more than
that and anyone who thinks that this
will be resolved through an election or
something like that is not thinking
clearly
these pressures and divides have been
building up for more than a century just
as roe v-- wade didn't magically end the
debate over human rights or abortion a
single election been a series of
elections is not going to bridge the gap
between two dominant cultures Hillsdale
College under it's very able leadership
understands the seriousness of the
problem and the insufficiency of many of
the current approaches to tackling
American problems we don't need
rearguard action tisk tisk emedia for
being historically wrong we need a lot
of people the kind of people who have
the education that Hillsdale provides
who fully understand these documents and
these beliefs that define us as
Americans so that we can do intellectual
battle to fight and win and not to
simply conserve some tiny piece of what
we used to have as our country's divides
become greater and more worrisome we
need more Americans who understand the
history of our founding the philosophies
that undergird it and what divided
government seeks to accomplish this is
being done in the context of a movement
in this country to erase our history in
progressive madrasahs essentially that
reimagine these things with a media that
seeks obfuscation rather than
enlightenment the main thing that gives
me hope right now is classical liberal
arts education my children attend a
school a classical Lutheran school that
is staffed by Hillsdale graduates that
is the number one thing I'm happy about
in my life right now
it is unclear frankly if the Republic
will survive the progressive onslaught
being waged against it right now but if
our founding ideals are to live on it
will be through the students educated
here inculcated with virtuous character
refined through challenging study and
sent forth with purpose thank you
and in general I prefer to answer
questions so we have time for some
questions so thank you mrs. Hemingway we
do now have time for Q&A please make
your way to the microphone if you have a
question or I can just ramble more to I
mean I was the one that asked that
question of mark last evening and I'm
very troubled by what's going on in the
media I guess my question to you would
be how do we battle the media being a
cabal with the left and the progressives
when there's no punishment for them
either making it up or twisting it to
favor what they're doing I understand
like I said last night Sullivan V New
York Times but there's got to be a way
that someone can hold the press
accountable if somebody falls on my
property in Florida they can sue me if
I've been neglectful my gosh some of
these reporters they'd have to be blind
not to uncover some of the stuff that
they should be talking about so I'm
sorry for taking up time but no that's
my favorite thing to talk about so I
would like yes to add to this by the way
did you know that Justice Thomas had a
little note this last year where he
mentioned that it might be time to
revisit New York Times versus Sullivan
yes so the issue there is that I
actually think the press might be the
biggest threat to press freedom right
now and you saw in in recent years you
saw that media inability to protect
people's privacy actually led to some
judgments against prominent media
figures there was the Gawker case where
Hulk Hogan sued them and won and
destroyed Gawker because of their
willingness to just publish something
that had no news value that that really
harmed his life and it was the failure
of that media outlet itself and other
media outlets that softened the ground
to enable that kind of
when against a media company and I think
you're seeing that with this willful
deliberate malicious behavior by some
media folks the principles in journalism
that we have that we're taught should
have been enough to prevent what
happened in Covington and they weren't
and the idea and I don't I'm not saying
I think he'd necessarily that this kid
who's sued everybody under the Sun raagh
oh that he'll win but he has and he has
I think a solid case to get something
they tried to destroy him and they had
no reason to do it they didn't gather
facts before they did it and there are
some legal vulnerabilities that they
have but more than that I think it's
important for people to not ascribe to
the media a cultural power that they no
longer have and this is something where
we have generally regarded them as
having the right to set conversations to
dictate what conversations will be they
get to moderate presidential debates and
that power was given to them on the
assumption that they would take that
responsibility seriously and that they
would be fair well they're not and they
haven't been for a long time so people
need to start thinking about other ways
to be the Democratic National Committee
announced that it wouldn't do anything
with Fox News because unlike the other
media outlets they might get gentle
pushback at Fox News and it was
interesting to see how people responded
to it including I think a lot of people
at Fox were saying accurately we're fair
we should not be punished for being fair
just because other media outlets are so
crazy on the left but it is kind of
weird why Republicans just agree to go
on these media outlets that are
extensions of the Democratic Party that
are actually leading the Democratic
Party it seems like maybe they should
think about whether that's working out
for them or what happens when to get to
a point of truth you have to go through
so many of the underlying false
assumptions that undergird each question
that it's not worth your time or that
you won't get fair treatment so anyway
yes there's some legal opportunities but
more than anything I think people just
need to stop treating them as if they
have a
cultural power that they no longer have
hello first of all I'd like to say I I
think of you and Kimberly's rustle as
the dynamic duo and we are so grateful
and just what I encourage you I'm sure
it's not easy two quick questions for
you one is the term progressive to me is
confusing because it's it's been also
applied to President Trump and so how
can the progressives be against Trump
Trump was also progressive so there's
some confusion about terminology in my
mind and then the other thing and even
more of interest right now is what would
your forecast be for the for this
impeachment process you see just those
three easy I'll just discard them right
away first up I just wanna say I use the
term progressive to refer to the
progressive movement this more than 100
year old movement that you know really
got going with Woodrow Wilson that has
this idea that human nature can be
conquered and that the Constitution is a
barrier that needs to be overcome I
don't like using the word liberal
because I think liberal is a great word
and I so I'm a little stubborn on on
that but progressive also sounds like a
nice word we want to progress we want to
do well but the actual movement is very
evil and has a lot of bad bad baggage
that it should be held accountable for
I'll do impeachment but just really
quickly the first thing you said about
it being difficult to speak against the
hive mind I I'm not saying that it's
it's always easy but I get very
frustrated when people I hear a lot of
people say oh this moment is so
exhausting and they say oh it's just
Trump is so exhausting I'm just
exhausted by everything and you hear a
lot of conservative pundits say this or
you know Republican leaders so we have
to do this again and I keep thinking it
is such an easy job compared to most
jobs to get to write for a living
or go on TV for a few minutes or do a
radio show or something like that that's
relatively easy compared to what
everybody else is doing and that you get
to do it is not exhausting and if you
find it exhausting you probably
shouldn't do it anymore because there
are a lot of people who are counting on
you to articulate conservative
principles or to advocate for different
things and if you don't if you can't
muster the energy other people can so
just head on out but anyway that's a
little so I thought as for the
impeachment the impeachment thing I
predicted he would be impeached already
so I'm a little bit behind schedule on
that and I don't really know I would
have just assumed like I said I thought
it would have happened already so when
this started I thought well of course
it's gonna happen I take such extreme
delight in how we're still trying to
figure out what we're gonna impeach him
for like the impeachment is a foregone
conclusion but like well what should we
you know what can we find here which is
not how it should go but and I and I
still assume that they will I will say
this rollout is going much more poorly
for them than all of their other
attempts and that might actually prevent
impeachment from happening and when the
Russia hoax started you saw a lot of
people in Washington DC take it
seriously on both sides of the aisle you
almost saw people hoping it were true as
a way to get rid of him and you saw a
lot of Republican leaders and political
pundits and whatnot say I don't know
this sounds really serious and that
enabled things to get crazy and it gave
the people running this operation a lot
of power and with this thing I just
thought it was interesting that right
away people were like yeah doesn't sound
like much because they're so they've
already been through the Cavanaugh thing
they've already been through the Russia
thing and all the other cultural things
like the Covington boys and everything
else like that that they're not willing
to just accept what the media claimed or
big issues not to mention that every
piece of actual information you get just
like with Russia they'll promise a
bombshell and then when you read it
you're like yeah that doesn't sound like
much and so what I'm mostly interested
in is how Republicans don't seem to be
playing along with it
that's surprising to me they seem to be
pushing back hard you have people
attempting to censor Adam Schiff for
colluding with the whistleblower before
the whistle was blown which is just so
fishy and he is a fishy person and this
is a part of a pattern for him of saying
things that are false you have people in
the Senate pushing back hard against the
idea that that is not legitimate to ask
Ukraine to explain why it meddled with
Hillary Clinton in our 2016 election so
it might not go as well for them I'll
start by echoing the compliment about
how good a fighter you are for what we
believe in thank you for that
you talked about the the passion and the
sacrifice and the commitment of the
founding generation so any thoughts
suggestions on how to make Liberty
passionate again it's a big question
that I'm not sure I have enough of a
good thing to respond to but I am
hopeful I'm always kind of hopeful part
of it is that there really are some
people who seem to be willing to stand
up in difficult scenarios part of it is
that as things get more impressive I
think it makes choices more clear for
people we are really just living in the
fruition of decades of progressive
education and what it has done to a lot
of people but there are a lot of people
who were not educated that way and who
do love what we have here and understand
that it needs to be fought for I wonder
if we're too comfortable to actually
have the fight that we need to have and
that is a risk but you don't pray that
things get worse so that people aren't
comfortable but I don't know I think
again it's perhaps a small thing but
speaking about why we're here I do a lot
of hiring and I meet a lot of new
graduates and a lot of them do not
inspire confidence in me or give me hope
but the success rate of working with
Hillsdale graduates has been just
unbelievable they seem to be able to
think critically right clearly
understand the significance of what
they're talking about you do that enough
and you start having a good movement
how instructive is it for the future of
United States democracy with what's
happening in Hong Kong and with some of
the protesters carrying American flags
could you explain that a little bit more
what you're asking sorry what effect
this might have on China itself what
effect this might well have on our
perception of democracy around the world
I don't know I I think that
unfortunately a lot of this was already
lost by allowing Hong Kong to be handed
over and they already were on a pretty
tight timeline but we were thinking
another thirty years and it might be
much shorter than that before their
oppression comes I actually have friends
who are missionaries there who were
talking about the what they've been
focused on since they got there was just
the limited time that they have before
China takes over it
really takes over but realizing that it
might be even shorter is very harrowing
on the other hand it is so inspiring to
see that they understand what they're
fighting for and why they're fighting
for it and it does give you this glimmer
of hope you wish that we could do
something to help out with that which we
really cannot do much right now without
making the situation much worse probably
but I think one thing that's been
interesting about the Trump
administration is how much the attention
has turned to China as it should have
been for a long time and even our battle
with North Korea is best understood as a
recognition of China's growing power
they've been so smart and savvy about
how they are building and accruing power
and influence across the globe but if we
lose that stronghold that's bad one
great thing the financial markets their
China might not want to mess with and
that might give the people there some
leeway to continue with their efforts
malee yeah I'm still stuck back on
Benghazi I just found it incredible I
come from the home district of trey
Gowdy and I thought for sure here to
have her dead to rights on that one and
nothing happened so if you could speak
to Benghazi but the other thing that I'm
really excited to know is who writes the
Democratic talking points that come out
every morning and it says the same thing
all across the media spectrum who does
that I mean it actually does probably
come out as talking points that you
really do get when you're on TV or when
you're in communications people just
send you what they think the talking
point should be it is entirely possible
that they are just getting the same
shared what it sounds like might be
exactly what's happening but it's also
true that people sometimes don't need
talking points because they already
agree with the agenda and so they just
kind of know what to say yesterday it
came out that Adam Schiff had worked
with this whistleblower before it came
out which a lot of people were saying it
seems like Adam Schiff knows a lot about
this whistleblower before it came out
and the media said that's a conspiracy
theory and you should stop saying it it
turns out the people who were saying
that were absolutely right the New York
Times spun it in the nicest possible
fashion they were like okay Adam Schiff
was working with the whistleblower in a
clearly partisan action designed to get
impeachment but don't worry it's all on
the up-and-up
and you saw it and you saw all the media
people just kind of pair at this nothing
to worry about yes Adam Schiff lied to
me personally when he said he hadn't
talked with him but nothing to worry
about
but you saw other people rejecting that
and that made me happy about the
Benghazi thing one of the things I've
learned by covering these really complex
situations is just how effectively many
people have weaponized complexity and
also how difficult it is to hold people
accountable when you don't have a lot of
key people helping out you can control
Congress but you don't have control of
you know the Department of Justice where
you might be able to encourage something
to happen or or what not
the Benghazi report that came out was
actually you know just showed that a lot
of people who had questions about it
were right and there's so much more that
would be interesting to look into there
about why we were in Libya in the first
place who had personal financial
interests there and whatnot but the
people are very good at avoiding
accountability and if you don't have a
really clear plan of action to come up
against it it probably won't work well
the Russia thing is maybe the only thing
that there will be a little bit of
accountability for it you have the
Inspector General report coming out
within the next month inspector general
reports are extremely boring and I and
they're written almost in a way to
preserve the agency that they serve but
these recent inspector general reports
from the Department of Justice have been
absolutely explosive I mean talking
about really bad things that James Comey
has done recommending him for criminal
prosecution even if that was declined by
the Department of Justice saying about
the damage he's done to the Department
of Justice and whatnot and to the FBI
and I expect this next report will be
more of the same and that there might be
actual actions taken even though it only
is going to deal with surveillance and
attorney general bar and this prosecutor
Durham really are looking into the
origins of the probe and for me I would
just almost be happy to just get
straight answers it would also be nice
to hold people accountable and if they
don't hold people accountable I worry
about again the preservation of the
Republic people have already seen in
repeated fashion that if you are with
one set of people you can get away with
you know quite literally murder and if
you're with another set of people any
little thing you do wrong will put you
in prison and that is not sustainable
for confidence in our institutions so I
hope that even though people don't want
to hold people accountable that they
recognize that it would be a much worse
problem for the country if they don't we
have time for one more question okay
talk there about the so-called
conservatives that aren't quite so
conservative its kebab they decide what
the Democrats it's sunny an expression
of they sort of run with the Fox and
hunt with the hounds and you know I get
twenty please from the Republican Party
to donate throughout the day I'm getting
right now and then I had forty one
representatives retiring and pulling out
now twenty so I I think you're
absolutely right it's you need people
that have are there with conviction not
just question you want to question well
he the issue of a surrogate City I
thought we fought a civil war about that
and when I talked to people in pardon to
justice and they assured me they're
going to go after individuals to control
the cities because cities don't declare
their you know it's people that make
these statements and and why hasn't the
Justice Department go on aggressively at
those individual layers that are in
charge of any cities okay yes okay
thanks I thought that was about in
sanctuary cities well it is actually a
pretty complicated situation depending
on the laws at hand and the Justice
Department has gone after some some
sanctuary city issues and I think
they'll continue to do so but if you
don't mind I actually kind of want to
talk about something else you just
raised about retiring representatives
and and whatnot which I think this is
one of those things that people have a
lot of conventional wisdom in Washington
DC that things must be really bad for
Republicans because you have all these
Republican representatives retiring and
that might be it might be true that
those people who all have this viewpoint
are correct it is also true that being
elected to office does not give you a
lifetime appointment and that sometimes
it's healthy for people to step down and
be replaced with other people it's been
a very tumultuous
period of time for people on the right
and also for people on the left but
since we're probably more interested in
what's happening on the right that
disruption has caused a lot of people to
realize that old alliances weren't as
effective as they thought they were and
it has caused some people to realize
that they are out of touch with many
voters that's actually a great thing and
it is also related to why we're here in
my view that there are certain people
who have handled this moment better than
other people certain institutions who
have handled the moment better part of
it I think actually is groups that are
not embedded in Washington DC seem to do
a better job at resisting the culture
there Hillsdale College other groups and
that they're throughout the country and
we did just start a graduate program out
in DC but the important thing about that
is there is a unique perspective that
what ails a lot of of what's happening
in our country is this reliance on the
administrative state over and against
our Constitution the way through is to
remember these constitutional principles
are balance of government that the
legislature should be legislating that
they should have better oversight of the
executive agencies and enforcing our
laws including border laws and sanctuary
laws and whatnot but a lot of people
haven't heard this despite all of the
money and effort that people have been
sending to DC and all the of all of
that's been happening there it's kind of
a new concept for people to realize how
to take on the bureaucracy and how
important it is for self-government and
so I think this is good that we are now
focusing some additional efforts in DC
with this message that is a little bit
different than what has been happening
for a long time okay thank you
[Applause]